hi my name is Gordon Ramsay welcome to
chef support today we'll be doing
Twitter right first question
Hannah question to those of you who are
good in a kitchen how do I mince garlic
without a press and I show you take the
clove of garlic this part of knife on
there and literally handle there and
that is super minced touch of salt in
there and just chop it and within
seconds you've got this paste because
look the salt keeps it together and it
stops it from using out onto the board
in ten seconds you've got this beautiful
minced garlic on the back of the knife
good question
now can cheese go bad I'm eating this
cheese and it tastes funny but I'm a bit
hungry come on Adam seriously the worst
thing to do with cheese is taking out
the fridge let it get up to room
temperature leave it out for 24 hours
and then refrigerate it that's the worst
thing you can do once you've taken out
and it's got really runny you have to
eat it or discard it this is from Giles
how do I know when my blue cheese has
gone off blue cheese is impossible to go
oh I think where it will turn sour
if it tastes bad get rid of it it's as
simple as that if you have any blue
cheese left over the freeze it mix it
into a butter and make a blue cheese
butter which is fantastic on top of a
steak especially with fresh off the
grill Rory
British food is so bad cheeky you
talk to me about food at least we got a
decent Prime Minister right Mary how do
I stop this weird egg water situation
with my scrambled eggs seasoning eggs at
the beginning turns it gray sees them at
the end that way you won't get water Ali
should I eat a hot pocket come on
seriously I mean there are so many more
exciting things to eat and a freaking
hot pot damn siree bands that how do you
grate mozzarella without crushing it
that's a really good question let me
show you something really important so
mozzarella get it nice and firm stick it
in the freezer for 10 minutes before you
start grating and literally use all the
grater
once you've started grating one side
turn it over and great more importantly
you get a much better yield
Caroline what you
when the sauce you're making has too
much chili in it I mean first of all
what you drinking if it's too hot
take half out yeah and then continue
cooking and let it down gently with
fresh tomatoes a great way of getting
rid of super hot chili Trevor right how
does this make you feel what is that
yeah that makes me feel sick Tana you
need to see a doctor
red wing fan I'm gonna make boneless
pork ribs about for how long and what
temp should I bake them at become tender
you know the boneless pork ribs for me
I cooked literally for 20 minutes and a
pressure cooker take them out glaze them
and then roll them for about 25 minutes
it'll be so tender wolf chamberlain
anyone know how the hell you cook a raw
artichoke I'm not asking for a friend
it's vinegar and water if there's no
vinegar in the water then they'll go
black so bring it up to the board put
the artichoke in and a teaspoon of
vinegar or slice of lemon and stick that
underneath the artichoke and tie it to
the actual core next Abbot gates right
can I freeze half a roast chicken I have
left over no don't do it the best thing
to do is actually shred the roast
chicken and make the most amazing soup
get a great chicken stock we should have
them a carcass that will last in the
fridge up to five or six days this is
from a me cooking device right I need to
make an enormous quantity of bechamel
would it be unwise to make it in one go
always try to maximize I'm keeping it
together same thickness at the same
amount of seasoning rather than several
batches next question Daniela how'd you
know if my mac and cheese is tender
without sticking my hand in a pot it
doesn't seem practical of course it
doesn't seem practical effect and a mac
and cheese make sure you blanch the
macaroni first two-thirds of the way and
just allow one third to finish in the
oven next oh no I have no horseradish to
make my cocktail sauce what do I use now
start of a cocktail sauce a touch of
chili sauce and then this little baby
here it's a Worcestershire sauce that
will give it the spice you need so don't
worry too much about the horseradish
Glen just straining chicken stock
through cloth help with skimming the fat
no it doesn't it makes it cloudy the
best thing to do on skimming of stock is
to let it set
and put a couple of ice cubes on top and
it will bring the fat up and for me I
get a slice of bread and I skim the top
of my stop with a slice of bread that
will absorb all the fat leaving that
beautiful stock underneath how'd our
cameras our cumberly without a cooking
torch
take an old spoon that you don't use put
it on the gas flame get it really nice
and hot and stick that lightly over the
sugar and it will caramelize it
instantly get it too hot then you'll
destroy the cream Michael Gordon trying
to decide between buying a Santa
Japanese knife or general will show use
for me the secret of a great knife is in
the handle so when you find a knife has
got the perfect handle it needs to be
weighted Henkel for the knife's I use a
great handle and a firm grip that's 90%
of the work get comfortable with the
handle it's the secret to great chopping
Precure right I've never tried
hollandaise sauce how do I know this is
right so that looks like it's a great
start
if you airy ate it it can take so much
butter if you don't lift up those egg
yolks then it splits basically breaks so
airy ate those eggs first and make sure
that heat and the meat is not too hot a
question from Steve G put too much salt
in my bolognese sauce
Robert ater will draw out the salt right
no Steve it won't
first of all take 1/3 of bolognaise out
a touch of sugar and let it down with a
touch of creme fraiche creme fraiche
will lighten up the flavor and get rid
of that salty taste Faye writes me
internally trying to figure out how I
would make a scotch egg do I use a
hard-boiled egg or do I wrap it after
with the sausage
so the delicate part there try and make
a soft-boiled egg and that way it stays
nice and creamy firm up the eggs and
then lay out the sausage really thinly
and wrap it nice and tightly good
question am i gourmet chef yet I mean
seriously you need to take two slices of
bread and stick them on your ears and
that's what you've got an idiot sandwich
got longshot but near enough self-taught
but still very much learning what can
you best recommend to complement a
Wellington the most amazing cream mashed
potatoes whole roasted carrots whole
roasted parsnips
glazed with honey and then
with an amazing Madeira sauce good luck
Sam what should I do with a dark green
part of the leeks can't see myself
throwing this better way really good
question
this part here okay is the magical
moment take your bay Leafs place in side
take your rosemary place that inside and
I spring at a time and then look follow
that up and then from there you just
roll it so it looks like this incredible
tea bag and what that does it puts
together an amazing bouquet garni tie
that on to your pan put the bouquet
garni in stock and it becomes this
incredible flavored beautiful teabag
cocoa right so Gordon in your opinion
what size pasta sheet should I use for a
good ravioli I use size 3 but they feel
a bit thick sighs - so forget buying
sheets make fresh pasta and get used to
cranking in that machine but the
thickness of the past that depends on
the filling so if your filling is cooked
then you can go super thin if it's
undercooked then you go super thick this
is from mo bucks
what is foie gras torchon Taschen isn't
is that there's at eat hours of cloth as
they poach in the cloth it protects the
foie gras so it's basically foie gras
wrapped in a tea towel and poached
Allison Gordon if I invite you to my
birthday party which you can i'm the
shittiest and the worst guess you'll
ever what a dinner party trust maybe
sorry Allison happy birthday that was
Gordon Ramsay chef support finished
thank for that